welcome back to new rockstars this is
the big question hey
i i'm hosting a big question again i
miss this show
this is a show that gives you too much
information about how many different
roadies are out there across the
multiverse working on their boom are you
looking for this bits
i'm eric boss i'm here today with marina
maestros it's been a minute marina
i know it's been a minute it's been a
minute for a big question for you and
it's been a minute
for for you and me together i know it's
i've been holed away in this blue
dungeon counting um
just weird little uh red blood lops
on a screen trying to figure out how
many black widow agents are out there
or a weird signs in the background of
the loki void
to see what other things have been
pruned but i realized that
we're starting to get a sense of how big
the marvel multiverse really
is so i think it's a fun opportunity to
talk about that today hit me with that
big question
exactly so loki has blown the mc
universe
wide open so before the series started
we
only knew about a couple of possible
timelines but now we know that there are
so many different timelines out there
just like
smashing into each other and that leads
us to this week's big question
which is how many timelines exist in the
mcu
a bunch goodbye everybody
[Music]
no eric no air no air no uh so you
remember a few years ago when the mcu
was just starting to grow we all had our
minds blown away when that first
avengers film came out and managed to
pull together all these individual
storylines and then things kept growing
and the industry just got bigger and
bigger we went to space
we learned about magic we shrunk into
the quantum realm
but it all existed in this just one
beautiful now we know sacred
timeline but then adventures end game
happened and whoa baby our universe
suddenly grew into a multiverse
branch timelines became a thing thanks
to a quick metaphysics lesson from the
ancient one so now our boy cap could go
live off a sweet retirement with his
main squeeze in a brand new timeline
let's hope he was able to invest in
google in that timeline if he didn't use
full idiot um so really
uh avengers end game kind of set things
in a certain way that there were at
least
four coexisting mcu timelines going on
you had the main
the prime mcu timeline that we now call
the sacred timeline we think
and then uh loki escaped into a branch
timeline
that got pruned but that's the one that
we started the loki series in and then
we believe stephen peggy's lovefest
happened
in another timeline
we assumed that that's all they were
doing for at least the end of the 40s
right
yeah that's what most americans were
doing back then they were just making
baby boomers who destroyed our
environment that we now have to live in
but then there's also this other
timeline that we call the no thanos 2014
timeline because thanos left that with
gamora
and nebula so that kind of left this
other variant timeline with with no
thanos in it so we know those four
now our understanding the multiverse has
been smashed into a smithereens once
again
thanks to the loki series and we know
there are so many more variants and
prune timelines out there
so i think we should add to those four
timelines to see if we can figure out
just how
big the non-marvel cinematic multiverse
is
and our logic here is that for every
variant
that implies some timeline whether or
not it was pruned
some timeline that either does exist or
once existed
every specific artifact that was left
over
that we see in the uh in the tva
represented
some other timeline and everything in
the void
and then anything else that might have
been mentioned on the tva
chrono monitor screen of a date in the
location of some nexus event so
um in the loki series we meet sylvie we
know she grew up on asgard that was one
timeline
uh then there's classic loki richard e
grant's character everyone's favorite
he's so great he's fantastic i want to
watch his life
there's even a theory that he could be
our same
loki uh had he did fake his death hattie
did
he did i didn't even question it
yeah you know that's the thing people
just don't question me i i just kind of
stammer out stuff and people are like
sounds good
but this guy uh faked his death against
thanos and then uh just kind of drifted
out into space for whoever knows how
long that was a whole other timeline
yep you have kid loki who killed thor
when he was a kid that was another
timeline
boastful loki we don't really know what
his whole thing was because he's a liar
alligator loki came from some timeline
where he ate the wrong neighbor's cat
then we have that martin guy josh fadim
is the guy's name he was the
son of the guy who worked at goldman
sachs and he was a very in episode one
he got pruned some other timeline there
right we have the loki variants that
mobius lists
there's five of them that he went
through one of them was the tour de
france guy
which uh was i believe a reference to a
year when the cup of the tour de france
went missing
so i think that was kind of linked to
loki there
well there was one guy watching that who
was like i get it
and he was on a bike and then he crashed
into something
then there was that one bearded variant
that uh young sylvie sees getting
arrested and she's like help him
he came from somewhere in marina he
mattered
don't think that just because he had one
line he didn't matter because he did
that one line was just the top piece of
paper of a long stack of lifelong
dialogue
and we'll never know what it was uh and
then of course president loki
he came from uh timeline and then his
whole army minus the one that we already
saw mobius list off so that was another
nine loki's so right there right there
that's 21 more timelines
added to the mcu boom you looking for
this
you're welcome so i believe we're at 25
right now i i don't know maybe we're 21
i don't i can't math but mourinho since
we know that all
tva employees are variants as well from
their own
timelines they also count so
oh god we got mobius and mobius coming
from a jet ski in timeline we have to
assume
yeah baby then we got ravana red slayer
uh and then we got some hunters we know
b15
there's c20 there's d90 there's u-92
and then casey our friend eugene cordero
he comes from a timeline in which he
doesn't know what fish are
i love him he's amazing and everything
then we have the woman in the library
who's shush loki and then the main
librarian we got the scanner clerk
the paperwork clerk and the cute little
cat uh young
sylves judge who's a different guy than
rent slayer and then that variant who
kind of looks like peggy carter we think
we don't know
yeah and then the guy behind the glass
is taking tickets
and then according to imdb there are 18
credited minutemen some of them get
killed by
sylvie uh and then uh five credited
analysts
but then there's like also eight tva
employees sitting in the courtroom
between
loki and young sylvie's trials and then
30 other we think background tva
employees and minutemen
that aren't quite credited but you see
at least
like uh three thirty or so extras that
are working around so
all of these employees that we see would
add to another 75 timelines to our
multiverse
god oh my god and i know you might be
asking
marina because i'm reading your mind and
i assume you're asking this
i am why couldn't some of them just have
been pruned from the same timeline no
that's not how nexus events work right
like you
you were that one nexus event that
skewed a new timeline into a new
multiverse
and the fact that it's pruned doesn't
matter there's still uh evidence of it
once existing
and maybe not all of them got pruned
maybe some of them lived on maybe the
tva is lying about
whether the sacred timeline really
doesn't exist in a multiverse i think
that's the case
right yeah so there are objects of the
tva as well
there's props every little thing magic
every little thing you do is magic every
little thing
needs to get pruned everything that
creates a timeline
so uh starting with the crap we see in
casey's
uh evidence locker there right so
there's 19 different infinity stones
oh whoa baby wow and then about
15 other objects there was like a rare
baseball card in there there was a
dagger there was a french military medal
it's a bit hard to tell but uh on ravona
rensselaer's shelf
there's a snow globe and there are 11
other objects
there's also that pen from fdr high
school that's important right now we can
move on to the nexus events that occur
in the series and are often shown on the
ticker on the chrono monitor screen
so sylvie makes three before we
officially meet her
uh they show one in france one in
oklahoma and then the wren faire
uh that's in oshkosh wisconsin then
sylvie bombs the sacred timeline and we
get
26 more branches that's listed on those
screens of different
areas in years and i did a whole video
breaking them down
i don't know if that's ever really that
important but you did it anyway
those timelines presumably existed and
they were pruned and everything's fine
now but then for various other shots of
10 pads and chrono monitors like when we
just see different locations flickering
across and in my breakdowns they say hey
look that says seoul south korea
that adds up to 18 more nexus events so
that adds
47 more timelines to our growing
multiverse oh my god
i know i know but now it is time to look
at the void
that we saw in episode five in this
place
just full of it it's full of prune
timelines
do it eric do it we can do this let's do
this thing
so there's the big easter eggs we see
the lighthouse of alexandria the sphinx
and the pyramids uh the thanos copter
the giant yellowjacket helmet the heads
of the living tribunal
in total there are 19 of those that uh
that i spot in episode five now in that
bowling alley
where the loki's hideout is there's more
items like the plebis arcade game
space mission pinball the candy canes
that are all part of the
santaland set up the ecto cooler heist c
box it's difficult to say what came from
the bowling alley what might have
already been there
and what was salvaged from the void and
brought in there
but it's safe to assume that among all
that's been collected
that we can see there's probably at
least 20 more timelines representing the
bowling alley i mean there's also that
old 1930
monster book there's the roxcart wine
that they're drinking
like you gotta assume that's like a very
safe estimate
yeah we're even we're even lowballing it
there now sylvia wakes up at a bus and
it's picked up by a
mobius and a pizza car so that's two
more that bus came from somewhere
uh the pizza car came somewhere on horse
that all right just uh
you're you're uh all right you know what
has anybody said that the pizza car
could be from i mean this is it's all
disney but the pixar when what's in
pizza planet
the pizza planet yeah a lot of people
have asked about that
um no you were the first one marina well
done because you were really reported
this
no there are there been people to ask
but you're the first person to ask me in
person
and oh good i'm holding my starbucks
straw right now
and that's important
oh you're gonna have to cut a bunch of
that no we really this is a good stuff
we're leaving
okay okay no cuts no hey it could be a
pixar
pizza planet thing it's just i'm trying
to remember a pizza planet ever had like
a springy slice of pizza i think it was
a rocket ship
usually on the top of the camera but
each
in each movie where pizza planet shows
up it kind of takes a different form you
know
so you see pizza playing it throughout
the ages i'm gonna say this
go for it yes yeah it is it is i wanted
mobius to show up as like
is that too hard to ask
that's so cute good cheryl that would
have been cute but
alas i dropped my starbucks straw i'm
gonna
pick it up with my monkey feet and i got
it yes
because this is important now finally we
got to consider the buildings in the
void each building likely represents its
own prune timeline right because a lot
of them are specific there's the
gang tower there's the bowling alley
there's dom's barber shop
i assume that's where um toretto went
before
yeah loki's our family we get this
sweeping shot of what we call the
downtown area the void it's hard to see
them all but each building
we think is a separate timeline it
includes you know there's a sanctum
sanctorum
among them uh it looks like there's
about 70 buildings as we sweep into
oh my god and then in the background
there's another huge collection of
buildings on that horizon
so i think based off of the area we just
passed that other area seems
bigger i think that's safe to say it's
another hundred buildings oh my gosh
you know what yeah why not why not yeah
i think like in in a downtown area of
any major city
it's about it's quite it's about a
hundred you've gotta say at minimum at
minimum
now uh there's also some random items
that we're able to see in the void like
you know there's power lines there's
just a stray house there's subway cars
something dropped from the sky
that looked freshly pruned that everyone
was like it's cat but i'm like it
doesn't look like cap it looks like some
weird ship
that has like a a trombone
[ __ ] funnel at the end all in all
those kind of add to another
40 more timelines of those oh my god
yeah so the void in total adds uh 251
more timelines
wow so once we add all of this up we get
a grand total of
but
444 known timelines in the mcu
multiverse
quite a step up from the four we knew
about just a little a month ago
but guys we got 10 episodes of what if
coming up
so that's at least 454 and we don't know
if certain mcu properties might have
taken place
in alternate timelines like red guardian
was talking about fighting cap he could
have been fighting steve rogers or
isaiah bradley
so what cap was he fighting if not some
multiversal traveler
is that 456 we're at now and then
in the finale when he remains talks
about the other kang variants who ward
with each other
throughout that tableau it was implied
to be infinite though we saw precisely
17 of them
and then at the end of the episode as
b15 and mobius look at the chrono
monitor screen add those up that's 53
more new timelines four main and then
call me crazy but i tried to count all
those lightning bolt branches orbiting
the citadel here's how i did it i took
the frame where it looks the most
spider-webby before we cut away from it
and then i estimated that about 10
of the visible frame shows about from
what i can count 180 timeline strands
so multiplying that up by 10 for this
one frame that's
1800 more timeline strands but then if
you think about it this frame just shows
one wedge of what the full timeline ring
would be
so based on the angle i'm going to say
this shows about 1
6 of the full loop so that would mean at
least 10
800 branches formed when the sacred
timeline fractured probably a lot more
than that but this is what we can see in
the episode so adding up our the number
we got up to 456
plus 17 plus 53 plus 10 800 we have at
least marina
11 326 timelines
that we have visual or corroborating
evidence for confirmed in the mcu
nice work eric that's so
much thank you and thank you to uh
off-screen producer brandon barrick he
helped me track down a lot of these ones
it's a lot of counting a lot of our job
people are like how do you find all
these easter eggs i'm like i literally
stick my face close to the screen and
brandon can tell you this now he had to
do this
stick your face close to the screen and
then grab your starbucks
[ __ ] where'd it go yeah yeah grab your
starbucks
this is why it's important and i count i
go one two three
four five six seven and then i screen
grab it and i bring it into photoshop
and i brighten and i adjust the contrast
i'm like oh that letter is q
e and g got it you gotta do the dirty
work it's not any brilliance it's just
doing the damn homework and being
willing to delay your video a day
well done eric well done brandon there's
no magic to this well
um if you haven't already seen we've
dropped some exclusive black
widow-inspired merch over at
newrockstarsmerch.com there's our
limited edition latest obsession shirt
and some cool stickers
other shirt designs inspired by the
movie you can even get a red
ledger journal it looks great so whether
you're getting the hourglass design the
russian nesting doll design
they all look pretty great uh and this
journal ah just a great place to write
down all the people you've assassinated
or just all the boys you're crushing on
and you can find all those and all of
our other merch options at
nrockstarsmerch.com
also great place to pick up one of our
loki inspired shirts
which hopefully there's still some while
supplies last but before we dive into
our bite size questions next that marina
is going to answer for us
just some words from the folks that help
us bring you big question
credit karma so credit karma wants to
help you with a credit karma money spend
account
get rewarded for good money habits
credit karma money is a brand new
checking account where you can win cash
reimbursements for making purchases with
credit karma money when you use your
credit karma money debit card you can
win
daily instant karma purchase
reimbursements on items up to five
thousand dollars just pay with your
credit karma money debit card and if you
win
you'll be notified on the spot and your
instant karma cash will be added back to
your spend account credit karma money
has already given away over three
million dollars in instant karma
open your fdic insured spend account for
free and when you make a purchase
between july 1st and july 23rd you'll be
automatically entered to win 1 million
thanks to credit karma money right now
visit creditkarma.com
win money to open your free account and
start winning with instant karma go to
creditkarma.com
win money to sign up for free and start
winning instant karma that's
creditkarma.com
win money instant karma is sponsored by
credit karma no purchase necessary
exclusion system supply c rules banking
services provided by mvp bank inc member
fdic
maximum balance and transfer limits
applied also
thanks to me undies for sponsoring this
episode there are some simple pleasures
in life that help to make your day
a little better when you have enough
ketchup for every fry
or when you find the perfect parking
spot or when your underwear is so
comfortable you want to do a little
dance when you put it on
well me undies has the most dance for
the underwear i have ever worn
they're breathable super soft
underwear comes with everything from
classic colors
to ridiculous prints in a range of sizes
from extra small to four extra large
never leave your couch again with a me
undies membership
a monthly subscription that sends you
new pairs right to your door so when you
[ __ ] right through your
your boxers every first friday
you don't have to worry a new order is
coming right your way
uh this monthly subscription sends your
new pairs right to your door each month
you'll choose
new undies socks and a bralette and
pick the style and color or print that
feels about
you plus enjoy discounted pricing and
free shipping and exclusive early access
to new launches love your butt and get
the membership
meundies also has their problem-free
philosophy
if you're not satisfied with any product
for any reason they'll refund or
exchange it no caveats no questions
so to get 15 off your first order in
free shipping go to meundies.com
bigquestion that's meundies.com big
question
hey marina yeah buddy are you ready for
some bite-sized questions
yes i am let's do this so our first
question comes from alice rose on
discord thank you for supporting us by
the way
uh what are the ragnarok rules for
asgard and the mcu
versus the comics also if regular
asgardians die during ragnarok will
they come back uh yeah great question
thank you alex rose keep those questions
coming
everybody so the events that lead up to
ragnarok in the mcu are fairly
straightforward
this was probably done to simplify the
event since they have to pack
all of ragnarok into a single film so we
don't blame them for that
um the crown of sirter needed to be
reunited with the eternal flame to
restore searcher to
full power and destroy asgard in the
comics
ragnarok is depicted as more of a cycle
that repeats itself
over over and over over eons of time it
is the death and destruction of asgard
and some of its gods but
it's also their rebirth so the cycle of
ragnarok was set in motion
by those who sit above in shadow and
these are sort of primal gods who feed
off of the energies that are released
during ragnarok which
actually makes sense scientifically
because i watched a documentary on black
holes and they actually released
radiation which is crazy because we used
to think that nothing came
out of them isn't that why and now we
know wow that's fascinating
i know it's real science and scary
according to the prophet valla there are
several events that precede ragnarok so
an incredibly powerful winter known as
the thimble
winter i'm just gonna i'm i'm not
norwegian but this is how
i'm gonna pronounce things go for it go
for it i'll do my best
um winter falls over asgard
causing panic among the citizens and
eventually leads to infighting because
everybody's struggling for resources
and then also loki will trick the blind
god coder
hodor hood the dirt
uh into killing uh baldr the brave
thor's half
brother so once these events happen
heimdall sounds the horn announcing
ragnarok has begun
the next events are loki leads trolls
and
giants into asgard across the bifrost
heimdall will destroy the rainbow bridge
but he will also be
killed by the invading army thor and
loki will meet for their final conflict
but they will be interrupted by the
midgard serpent and then
finally searcher shows up from muslim
and finishes off asgard that sounds
german yeah
yeah it's normal i don't know i'm not
very good at it
uh whoever is nordic in the internet is
like just shaking you know they've had
to deal with people mispronouncing
their uh their language all the time and
we apologize every time because we love
you guys
yeah sorry you got long words
oh it's true um so then eventually a new
race of gods rises up
from the ashes and this whole thing
begins again
so all this happens before around the
time of 81
um when jesus is like really busy during
that time yeah being a baby and doing
nothing yet um but
some of these my wife might be so mean
to the baby jesus
it's just not getting killed did not
have an easy life born in a manger
put in some work put in some work buddy
but
so some of these things some of these
events were actually different than how
vola described
so like for example odin is killed by
the fenris wolf
loki and heimdall kill each other and
thor was killed by the make guard
serpent's
venom and another previous ragnarok
occurred around a million bc according
to bury thor's great grandfather
but some of the events of that ragnarok
also didn't align with the prophecy
uh-huh prophecy says never mind what the
prophecy says so
the other question is but what about the
mcu so ragnarok was pretty much just
searcher destroying asgard
but some other events from ball's
prophecy in the comics came
true like loki brought the frost giants
into asgard in the film thor
and odin died in thor ragnarok and even
heimdall died
right like eventually yeah yeah shortly
after a few months after
yeah that counts so there were some
elements of walla's prophecy that did
come true
and um just so we don't think it's over
the cycle continues
because new asgard has been established
in tomsberg
it sounds german every time yeah
yeah uh in townsburg norway and they
have a new ruler in valkyrie which i'm
very excited about and as for as
guardians being brought back they don't
really get reborn like the god figures
do they
prefer to make people the old-fashioned
way oh
yeah that's my favorite way in tubes oh
yes well some of us were assembled in
laboratories
yeah i'm not talking about a test two
baby i was built with
the parts of dead convicts and then
philip flipped a switch
you're a frankenstein i'm not familiar
with the reference i was bill with the
bodysuit
dead prisoners what's wrong with that
anyhoo excellent job marina what a very
thorough
uh answer to that question okay so
another question from one of our
uh discord users we have uh janice
julius
who asks can the pheromones or anything
even remotely close to them from the
black widow movie
exist thanks giannis um okay so this is
actually
kind of a wild answer so whether or not
a secret pheromone weapon exists similar
to the one from black widow we don't
know
but um i'm pretty sure like cinnabon is
the same thing because like you can't
be close to it like you know what
happens is you just turn into a cartoon
and do that floaty thing yeah i was
about to say
like a pie on the windowsill and you
just float over to it and then you like
garfield scarf it i'm not
numb yeah so they obviously already have
a technology it's
called cinnamon but what's wild is that
we do know that the us government has
done research into the potential of
harnessing pheromones so
in 2007 the us army backed a study
called
identification and isolation of human
alarm pheromones
they studied the bodily fluids of
subjects participating in their first
ever
tandem skydive which i have done and is
a lot a lot of chemicals going on
mostly mostly you're like oh my god i'm
gonna die and then
a lot of adrenaline stuff like that so
that makes sense
so they were trying to find a certain
chemical in human fear sweat and by the
time i got on the ground i was drenched
oh fear sweat yeah i've sweated buckets
of fear sweat
it's great very valuable to the
government yeah you should just donate
it next time and the pentagon through
darpa which is the defense
advanced research projects agency in
2004
commissioned a study called now stay
with me on this
integrated system for emotional state
recognition for the enhancement of human
performance and detection of criminal
intent
wow this is a whole origin story for me
it is
eric um close but they did want to
develop systems that could monitor
people's pheromones to determine their
intent so this is crazy
they wanted to uh make something and you
can think of it as like a security
measure for places like military bases
or airports
so they could see if someone was
emitting pheromones that indicated they
were about to do something bad
wait so is this like the tsa agent
saying like it smells like a terrorist
lock them up
yeah kind of yeah exactly but
it didn't work obviously because you
know it doesn't
and also but they also do like whenever
i go through the airport they always
like smell me a lot so
they do i mean that's just kind of what
the dog does right but they're like well
we learned this from the dog
yeah while you're smelling down there
just because i'm nervous and they're
like she's gonna do something
but this is even crazier there's another
more infamous project that the military
considered uh in 1994 1994
okay yeah the united states air force
laboratory put together a three-page
proposal
for a this is insane this is and i'm
quoting a gay bomb
okay hold on yeah i've ordered one of
those at the abbey report
they taste great and they actually are
really good uh
the concept behind this 7.2 million
dollar research proposal was simple
drop a bomb that sprays female sex
pheromones over enemy troops in order to
make them sexually attracted to each
other
they'd be too busy to fight
well which you know of course this idea
is like absolutely insane
when the project was rejected but just
think about somebody sat there and wrote
that proposal
and they were like it's gonna cost 7.2
million dollars we could probably just
get these soldiers to
each other instead of fighting instead
of pheromones they could have just like
dropped a bunch of viagra and everybody
just gone
they could yeah and they're just horny
they can't control it yeah you know
uh i mean that's a real bong hit idea
man um but so pheromones are part of our
genetic makeup
and there is research to suggest that
they do subconsciously affect the
choices we make
however we have not been able to unlock
the technology to weaponize these
pheromones against us
not yet anyway so we're safe for now
all right well thank god okay marina we
got time for one
bunch of scrap question and i really
like the question this week
it is have you ever found yourself in a
position
where you have been right about
something but no one believes you
i i mean this is still unprovable yes
many times no one everyone believes you
but no believes me
but this is this is still to this day no
one believes me and it's fine
but i know i'm right i live in in la
and my childhood home is in la in a
suburb
and um it's not like
where wild animals would be but i was
like 13
and my room was on the second story and
my window faced the backyard and at like
two or three in the morning i heard like
a
really strong like something shaking the
branch of a tree and i was like what
so i like opened the window looked out
and granted it was dark but
i am i am right i'm right that there is
a monkey
in the tree because it's a pine tree
like my neighbor's tree is a pine tree
and it's giant it's like a redwood it's
huge and in order to shake those
branches you have to be
so strong and it was shaking not like a
little bit it was like
like it would look like it was going to
snap the branch off and i was like
and i ran into my parents room and i was
like wake up there's a monkey in the
yard and they were like
no there's not you're a child
yeah go to bed sleep stupid i went to my
brother's room and i was like
wake up there's a monkey in the yard he
was like shut up no go back to bed
and i was and i just sat there and
watched this monkey be in my
yard for like 15 more minutes or
whatever and then if
i left and no to this day no one
believes me however here's my evidence
that it might have
that i think it's true in burbank and
pasadena
in like in la little suburbs there's
literally parrots
green parrots that have heard of the
parrots yes they're real
and they're around and they've escaped
because they escaped the la zoo and now
they reproduce and they're just like out
in the wild
so it's not out of the question that
something some [ __ ] escaped the la zoo
and was in my
yard now can you just i by instinct even
now
even though this is a story i believe
you're true when my first gutted stick
was like
no she didn't i needed i know i know
what kind of monkey was it was it like
the
you know capuchin like indiana jones bad
dates monkey no
it would have to have been like based on
the
scientifically based on the amount this
the the
the width of the branch and the strength
with which it was being shaken
i'm gonna say a small chimp well wait
okay so we're not talking monkey we're
talking ape this is yeah
you think it's a chimpanzee that you
like now it's harder for me to believe
i know it's chimpanzees it doesn't
matter it's fine i know i knew this was
gonna happen
i knew this was gonna happen this is
what happens to me every time i tell the
story it's fine it doesn't matter
i'm used to it not a city
being gaslit by everyone you know we've
all talked without you in the room
saying look
marina saw this monkey she was not
supposed to see the monkey the monkey's
gonna surprise her
in a couple years from now but she
cannot see the monkey i've told this
story
countless times not a single goddamn
person has ever believed me or even
thought it to be possible so it's fine
well shortly after i met you
whether it was at like a improv theater
or a bar or at a birthday party some
other friend i went to the bathroom and
the monkey was there smoking and said
one day she's going to bring up me
that she saw me outside of her window
where i don't know why
know it's a little russian or a little
french
yeah i don't know um uh
wow what a great story it's fine it's
fine
marina's monkey mystery
what's yours buddy i have to think for a
second because my problem is the
opposite
sometimes i get stuff wrong like a
trivia night with friends
and i'll be like i think it's azerbaijan
and we're like that sounds like eric
knows what he's talking about and
they'll say right down to zerbachan and
it's not azerbaijan
so i have the opposite problem i'm too
trustworthy
when you should doubt me more um but i
do
remember i mean you know how like there
are these injustices that happen to you
in grade school and they kind of stay
with you
but because you were like nine years old
no one thinks that
anything you say means anything yeah uh
well i went to
a catholic school in fourth grade oh
okay so you know how horrible that is
like you get a grade in religion i know
i know
uh yeah just spend whatever that extra
45 minutes a day teaching us more math
please
yeah really useful but no they uh in
fourth grade we alternated teachers so
we had one teacher who taught us
a certain subject whatever that block
style is yeah it's with one teacher who
was not our homeroom teacher who just
like hated everyone in our class like
she was so mean to us all the time
and i was a goody little two shoes i
always do my homework on time i never
got in trouble
never did anything bad so like everyone
would be so excited whenever i screwed
up or got in trouble
yes finally uh it was right at the end
of the school year
uh and i uh didn't you're supposed to
for your religion homework
you'd be getting an assignment you had
to do these certain pages of whatever
the exercises are
and at the end they did a thing called
family corner or something like that
where you had to sit with your parents
and do uh
like exercises with them read a bible
verse talk with them about whatever the
lesson was
and they said and for me i'm like i
would always do my homework on time but
my parents were just like getting drunk
or hanging out with their friends or
yelling at one of my other siblings i
couldn't always find time i'm one of
five
right so i would always we would have
two days to do our religion homework i
would always put that one off to the
second night
well for whatever reason our teacher
decided you know what
i'm mad at this class today i'm gonna
check in their homework on the first
date
like rather than the second day i'm like
but it's not due to the second thing and
she held us accountable for all that and
i'm like but i didn't know
that she's so intimidating and i was
like ah well the show for all those kids
she made a stand up as she yelled at all
of us and then she gave us an extra
assignment to do and i was so panicked
for getting in trouble that first time i
didn't write down exactly what page
numbers to do so i went home and i did
the page numbers
and i had my parents finally sign and
they're like whatever fine
oh my god uh i should just what most
kids did was they just forged their
parent's signature
yeah you were too honest yeah uh-huh
uh and then um but i did the wrong pages
and then the teacher got
really mad at me and she i was one of
two kids who [ __ ] that part of it
so she made us miss recess and because
it was the end of the school year the
recess that day was like a special party
for all the kids
and i wasn't allowed to go to it i had
to sit in her classroom
and she left and i finished she's like
you need to fill your page with i will
not i will not i will not and i did and
i
finished and she left she was gone she
left us
unattended and i'm like well i'm gonna
go back to the party
yeah and then she got super pissed at me
and screamed at me and then my homeroom
teacher who liked me she's like eric
what's wrong with you yeah and i tried
to explain i'm like
i didn't i have an excuse but but you're
not good at like arguing on your behalf
as a kid because you're a literal and i
couldn't explain that i didn't do
anything wrong
but i think this teacher was just glad
to nail me and even though it was a
stupid thing it's because it was just
like
yeah and justice wanted justice yeah if
you're like uh you know
a privileged white man and nothing bad
has ever happened to you
the one bad thing that has happened to
you or it wasn't your fault
just stays with you and haunts you but
for everyone else in the world [ __ ] like
this happens all the time
and i feel so bad for everyone has to
have just random injustices thrust upon
them
i get your oppression i understand it i
empathize
i'm with you i've had it just as hard as
you what am i saying
that's so funny little tiny baby eric
being like
but i did my homework i did it was like
why did you leave the room but because
it all began with i didn't belong there
to begin with
a good kid shut up but ultimately
i needed that i needed probably someone
to just be like you know you're a little
jerk
and you need to just have something bad
happen to you
if that that's so funny because if that
was the thing that formed you into the
human you are then
you know the anxiety written person
always crossing every t dotting every
eye
and then when you miss something and i
get have a nose
that too that teacher sounds nuts i hope
she was a substitute
yeah i think no she was a full-time
teacher
and she had the reputation of just like
nailing
every kid to the wall that she could the
nice the nice ones
the good ones i had the nice one the
other one was mean
uh but that's who that's what i had to
do with anyway
well what an episode this has been a big
question
i if i'm a little rusty i apologize it's
been a bit since i've done good question
i've just
enjoyed watching all of you guys and
co-hosted it you know mg is so funny and
you're so funny jessica's so funny
tommy's so funny so i just
i've been enjoying everything you guys
do um
do more of these in the future but if
not and
it's good to know it's been in good
hands um well
uh be sure to subscribe to the big
question podcast
wherever you get your podcasts uh follow
new rockstars
uh everywhere on social media and
subscribe here on youtube
follow marina at marina mastros on all
social media
follow me at ea boss be sure to check
out our great merch options again
newrockstarsmerch.com uh and we'll see
you next time
bye bye everybody look out for the
monkey
i shake the trees
[Music]
you